Traductor: Jenny Lam-Chowdhury
Revisor: Denise RQ
El principio de incertidumbre
de Heisenberg
es una del puñado de ideas
de la física cuántica
adoptada por la cultura popular.
Establece que nunca puedes
determinar simultáneamente
la posición y la velocidad
exactas de un objeto
y sirve de metáfora para todo,
desde la crítica literaria
hasta los comentarios deportivos.
La incertidumbre se explica a menudo
como resultado de la medición,
que la acción de medir
la posición de un objeto
cambia su velocidad o viceversa.
La verdadera causa es
mucho más profunda y sorprendente.
El principio de incertidumbre existe
porque en el universo todo se comporta
como partícula
y como onda al mismo tiempo.
En la mecánica cuántica,
la posición y velocidad exactas
de un objeto no significan nada.
Para entenderlo,
tenemos que pensar lo que significa
comportarse como partícula o como onda.
Por definición,
las partículas existen en un
único lugar en
cualquier instante de tiempo.
Podemos representarlo en un gráfico que
muestre la probabilidad de encontrar
el objeto en un lugar determinado,
que parecerá una punta,
100% en una posición específica
y cero cualquier otra posición.
Las ondas por otra parte, son alteraciones
que se propagan en el espacio
como las ondas
en la superficie de un lago.
Podemos fácilmente identificar
las características propias de su patrón
y, más importante, su longitud de onda,
que es la distancia
entre dos crestas consecutivas
o dos picos negativos consecutivos.
Pero no podemos asignarle
una sola posición.
Hay una buena probabilidad
de que esté en muchos sitios diferentes.
La longitud de onda es esencial
para la física cuántica,
porque la longitud de onda
está asociada a su momento,
la masa por la velocidad.
Un objeto a gran velocidad
presenta un mayor momento,
lo que corresponde
a una longitud de onda muy corta.
Un objeto pesado tiene mucho momento
incluso a poca velocidad
lo cual también significa
una longitud de onda muy corta.
Por eso no notamos la naturaleza
de onda de los objetos cotidianos.
Si lanzas una pelota de béisbol al aire,
la longitud de onda
es una mil millonésima de una billonésima
de billonésima parte de un metro,
demasiado pequeña para ser detectada.
Cosas pequeñas como los átomos
o los electrones, sin embargo,
pueden tener una longitud de onda
lo suficientemente grande
como para poder ser medidas
en experimentos.
Si tenemos una onda pura
podemos medir su longitud
y por ende, su momento,
pero no tiene posición.
Podemos determinar
la posición de una partícula,
pero al no tener longitud de onda
no podemos medir su momento.
Para conseguir una partícula
con su posición y momento,
debemos mezclar los dos dibujos,
para crear un gráfico que tenga ondas,
pero solo en un área reducida.
¿Cómo hacemos esto?
Combinando ondas
con diferentes longitudes de onda,
lo que significa darle a
nuestro objeto cuántico
alguna posibilidad de tener
un momento diferente.
Cuando tenemos dos ondas,
observamos que hay sitios
donde las crestas se alinean
creando una onda más grande,
y otros donde la crestas de una
coinciden con los valles de otra.
Como resultado se crean áreas
donde vemos ondas,
separadas por áreas
que no presentan ninguna.
Si agregamos una tercera onda,
las áreas que no presentan
ondas se agrandan;
añadimos una cuarta
y el área sigue creciendo,
mientras que las áreas
con ondas se estrechan.
Si seguimos agregando ondas
creamos un grupo de ondas
con una clara longitud de onda
en una pequeña región.
Esto es un objeto cuántico
con dualidad onda-partícula,
pero para lograrlo
necesitamos perder certidumbre
sobre su posición y momento.
Su posición no se limita a un solo punto.
Existe la posibilidad de encontrarla
en un rango a cierta distancia
del centro del grupo de ondas.
El grupo de ondas se creó
agregando muchas ondas,
lo que significa
que es muy probable encontrarla
con el momento correspondiente
a cualquiera de esas ondas.
Tanto la posición como su momento
son ahora indeterminados
y las incertidumbres están relacionadas.
Si quieres reducir
la incertidumbre de la posición,
haciendo el paquete de ondas cada vez
más pequeño, tienes que añadir ondas
lo que crea mayor incertidumbre
del momento.
Si quieres determinar mejor el momento,
necesitas un grupo de ondas más grande,
o sea, mayor incertidumbre
para la posición.
Ese es el principio de incertidumbre
de Heisenberg,
formulado por primera vez en 1927
por el físico alemán Werner Heisenberg.
Esta incertidumbre no se debe
a buenas o malas mediciones,
sino que es la consecuencia inevitable
de la dualidad partícula-onda.
El principio de incertidumbre no es
solo un límite práctico de la medición.
Es un límite de las propiedades
que un objeto puede tener,
inherente a la estructura básica
del universo mismo.